I was very very proud of the way that  the way the Toronto's responded the way  the first responders dealt with the  situation the way the police behaved  stephen amell post this video on  Instagram while Dan levy Jann Arden  Nickelback Tatiana maslany Colin Mochrie  and Brian Adams are all expressing their  sadness on Twitter Damian Lewis was  currently in Toronto shooting a movie  tweets what a welcoming inclusive city  it is and now devastation I hold hands  with you Toronto other American stars  like Patricia Arquette and girl group  fifth harmony are also sending support  and Britney Spears tweets sending my  love to the people of Toronto and all  those affected  [Music]